la regla de huel solo puede aplicarse a
compuestos monocíclicos sin embargo hay
algunos compuestos policíclicos que
parecen tener algún tipo de estabilidad
aromática y uno de esos compuestos es el
naftaleno aquí a la izquierda tenemos el
diagrama de puntos del naftaleno el
naftaleno es un solvente blanco que
comúnmente es el componente de la bola
de la polilla y por lo tanto tiene un
olor muy similar
esta ahora el naftaleno es aromático
pero no es tan estable como el benzeno
pero podríamos pensar en él como dos
anillos similares al benzeno fusionados
Y si tuviera que analizar una molécula
de naftaleno usando nuestro criterio
para la aromaticidad podría mirar cada
carbono en el naftaleno y podría ver que
cada carbono tiene un doble enlace por
lo que cada carbono tiene hibridación
sp2 y por lo tanto cada carbono tiene un
orbital p un orbital p sin hibridar Y
entonces hay un total de 10 carbonos en
el naftaleno Si vemos este dibujo a la
derecha vemos que cada uno de esos
carbonos tiene un orbital
p Así que puedo dibujar los orbitales p
en cada uno de mis
de esta manera ahora estos orbitales p
están uno al lado del otro lo que
significa que pueden traslaparse Y
entonces si piensas en Los criterios
para que un compuesto sea aromático el
naftaleno cumpliría el primer criterio
cierto porque puedes ver que estos
orbitales p se traslapan Y en este caso
tenemos deslocalización de electrones a
través de los dos anillos
Ahora cuando pensamos en el segundo
criterio el cual era la regla de jel en
términos del número de electrones pi que
tiene nuestro
compuesto continuemos analizando el
naftaleno aunque técnicamente no podemos
usar la regla de huel pero si observamos
la molécula podemos ver que hay dos
6 8 y 10 electrones pi el naftaleno
tiene 10
electrones
pi piensa en la regla de huel 4n + 2 si
n es = 2 4 * 2 + 2 es = 10 electrones Pi
y 10 electrones pi es un número de huel
Y entonces Parece ser que el naftaleno
cumple ambos criterios Aunque nuevamente
técnicamente no podamos aplicar la regla
de huel a compuestos po ccos pero esos
10 electrones pi están completamente
deslocalizados a lo largo de ambos
anillos y una manera de mostrar eso
sería utilizando estructuras
resonantes si
dibujá una estructura resonante para el
naftaleno podría
tomar estos electrones y moverlos aquí y
luego estos electrones se irían acá y
estos se moverán
allá y eso me daría otra estructura
resonante si continúo
dibujando los resultados del movimiento
de esos
electrones tendría ahora mis electrones
pi
aquí
así tengo un anillo similar al benceno a
la izquierda y
luego a la derecha aún tenemos estos
electones pi aquí así Ahora en este caso
he mostrado estos electrones pi de aquí
los he mostrado en el lado izquierdo
pero en la realidad esos electrones pi
están por arriba y por debajo de nuestro
enlace simple en términos de la
probabilidad de encontrar esos
electrones y entonces no tengo que
dibujarlos de la misma manera en la que
lo hice aquí podría
dibujarlos podría dibujarlos así déjame
continuar
poniendo Esto va a ser equivalente a
este diagrama de puntos por lo que estas
no son estructuras resonantes diferentes
Solo estoy dibujando una manera
diferente de representar esa estructura
resonante por
aquí podría mostrar esos electrones en
azul en este lado así déjame continuar
resaltando esos electrones los
electrones en azul están aquí y estos
dos dibujos son equivalentes después de
poner mis otros dos electrones aquí por
lo que los diagramas de puntos son solo
una manera imperfecta de representar la
molécula podría mostrar esos electrones
pi en la izquierda podría mostrarlos en
la derecha de hecho es lo mismo una vez
que haya dibujado esto Ahora puedo
dibujar otra estructura
resonante
puedo dibujar otra estructura resonante
de esta de
aquí podría mover estos electrones para
acá mover estos electrones para acá y
luego finalmente mover estos electrones
para
acá y entonces cuando continúo dibujando
el diagrama de puntos
resultante ahora tendría veamos estos
electrones pi aún están ahí y luego
yendo alrededor de mi anillo se vería
así hay un total de tres estructuras
resonantes que puedes dibujar para el
naftaleno nuevamente mostrando la
deslocalización de esos 10 electrones Pi
y mostrándote un poco de Por qué el
naftaleno exhibe algo de estabilidad
aromática no es tan aromático como el
benceno todos los enlaces del benceno
tienen exactamente la misma longitud
pero el naftaleno demuestra tener algo
de estabilidad aromática el naftaleno es
el ejemplo más simple de lo que es
conocido como hidrocarburo aromático
policíclico y hay bastantes ejemplos
diferentes de hidrocarburos aromáticos
policíclicos otro ejemplo sería algo
como el antraceno Y entonces hay muchos
muchos varos ejemplos de sistemas de
anillo que contienen anillos similares
al benzeno fusionados en todo el
sistema pero en lugar de enfocarnos en
esos Quisiera hacer otro ejemplo el cual
es un isómero del naftaleno y es
conocido como azuleno y el azuleno es un
hidrocarburo azul y bastante lindo es
extremadamente raro en química orgánica
tener un hidrocarburo tan azul también
tiene otras propiedades interesantes
tiene un momento dipolar aumentado
asociado con la
molécula también la densidad electrónica
está incrementada en el anillo de cinco
miembros aquí a la izquierda tenemos el
azuleno y aquí está el anillo de cinco
miembros por aquí en la izquierda y
resulta que hay más electrones en el
anillo de cinco miembros que los que
esperaríamos dándole un momento dipolar
mayor Y si pensamos en una posible
estructura resonante para el azuleno
podemos entender Por qué si tomo estos
electrones pi de aquí y los muevo acá
eso mandaría estos electrones a este
carbono si continúo y dibujo la
estructura resonante resultante tendría
un ion que se vería
así si pienso en mi cargas formales si
pienso en estos electrones en azul de
aquí esos se irán a ese carbono de
arriba ese carbono de arriba obtendrá un
par libre de electrones lo que le da una
carga formal de
-1 hay una carga formal negativa en ese
carbono y luego si pienso en este
carbono de
aquí este carbono perdió un enlace por
lo que acabará con una carga positiva
tenemos un carboca aquí así y si analizo
esta estructura resonante tiene dos
cargas formales en él pero si miro a la
derecha puedo ver aquí en la derecha hay
un anillo de siete miembros en la
derecha y viéndolo puedo ver que hay
seis electrones Pi y luego por acá tengo
un carbo cation y este es uno de los
ejemplos que hicimos en el último video
cada carbono tiene hibridación sp2 Y
entonces tenemos orbitales p traslapados
Y tenemos un total de seis electrones Pi
y entonces este anillo de siete miembros
es
aromático si veo por aquí a la izquierda
puedo ver que tengo un anillo de cinco
miembros y tengo algunos electrones pi
aquí Y estos electrones pi como vimos en
el ejemplo del naftaleno están siendo
compartidos por ambos anillos Así que
puedo pretender que esos dos electrones
están aquí en mi anillo y luego este
anillo también tiene electrones Como
esos con una carga formal de
-1 Y nuevamente en el último video vimos
que este I es aromático Tiene un total
de seis electrones pi continuaremos
resalt estándolo Así que
estos estos Y estos todos son electrones
pi cuando piensas en estructuras
resonantes seis electrones Pi y todos
los carbonos tienen hibridación
sp2 nuevamente te recomiendo ver el
video anterior para una explicación más
detallada de Por qué estos dos iones son
aromáticos y ya que estos iones son
aromáticos tienen algo de estabilidad
aromática y esta estructura resonante
aquí a la derecha es un mayor
contribuyente a la imagen global de la
molécula y la carga negativa está
deslocalizada a lo largo de este anillo
de cinco miembros de
aquí y la carga positiva está
deslocalizada o esparcida a lo largo de
este anillo de siete miembros Y eso es
lo que le da al azuleno un momento
Bipolar mayor así que hay un momento
dipolar mayor en el azuleno que el
esperado por el hecho de que esto nos
daría dos anillos aromáticos lo que por
supuesto significa estabilidad extra Y
una vez más Este y de aquí abajo era el
anión ciclo pentadien ilo y luego este
carbono de aquí era el cation ciclo
heptatrieno del video anterior la
redistribución de estos electrones
permite al azuleno absorber en la región
naranja lo que es difícil para la
mayoría de las moléculas orgánicas
porque es una longitud de onda mayor y
eso le permite reflejar la región Azul
la cual es nuevamente poco común
especialmente para un hidrocarburo y del
hecho de que es azul es de donde viene
esta parte del nombre como
azul Así que hay Solo dos ejemplos de
algunos sistemas de anillo que también
exhiben algún tipo de estabilidad
aromática